also für mich ist das mehr als
unverständlich dass unsere
bundesregierung jetzt ein stillstand
erreicht hat und diesen stillstand auch
hält sie jetzt ganz dringend
erforderlich entscheidungen zu treffen
und wenn eine bundesregierung
geschäftsführend im amt ist dann soll
sie die geschäfte gefälligst auch führen
und entscheidungen treffen haus
seehofers angedeutet 1000 migranten
täglich über unsere grenzen im osten im
süden und auch auf den flughäfen das
sind alarmsignale die darf man keine 14
tage mehr vor sich herschieben dann
werden wir wieder ein kollaps erleben
wir in 2015 an der südgrenze hatten das
ist angst mache sowas sagen einige die
im moment auf solche rechnungen blicken
auch auf die seehofer rechnungen ist das
angstmache wollen auch sie aufschrecken
alarmieren einfach nur nein das ist
keine angst mache das dann harte fakten
und das ministerium selbst operiert ja
mit den zahlen 1000 täglich und die muss
man verdammt noch mal ernst nähmen und
schnell handeln
was muss jetzt genau ganz konkret
passieren um die situation in den griff
zu bekommen
also zunächst mal hätte ich mir
gewünscht langsame antwort zu bekommen
auf meinen brief vor 14 tagen an herrn
minister da habe ich die drei konzerten
forderung gestellt ich habe zum einen
gesagt wir müssen temporäre
grenzkontrollen einführen an der grenze
zu polen um kontrolliert die zuwanderung
begleiten zu können zweitens müssen die
fluggesellschaften die dort den
russischen diktator unterstütze und die
menschen nach belarus bringen
sanktioniert werden durch die eu und
drittens bedarf ist ein ganz
konsequenten
außengrenzen der europäischen union und
polen wäre gut beraten sich dort an der
grenze zu bella wo es auch durch frontex
unterstützen zu lassen
[Musik]